تشهد بطوله كاس العالم 2022 في قطر غياب
كوكب من نجوم كره القدم الحاليين والذي
كان وجودهم سيجعل بطوله اكثر متعه وايثاره
على راسي المصري محمد صلاح نجم نادي
ليفربول والجزائري رياض محرز مهاجم فريق
مانشستر سيتي وزميله المهاجم النرويجيها
لاند هؤلاء فشلت منتخباتهم في بلوغ
المونديال لكن هنالك نجوم تاهلت منتخباتهم
لكنهم غابوا اما بداعي الاصابه او
الاستبعاد
كديفيدخيه حارس منتخب اسبانيا الذي
استبعده المدرس او المدرب الوسوا امريكا
في البريميم ليجا برفقه مانشستر يونايتد
وهناك النجم الفرنسيه
الذي اصيب في ركبته وخضع لجراحه ابعدته عن
كاس العالم في قطر
[موسيقى]
المشاركه في نهائيات كاس العالم حلمهن
راود وما يزن نجوم كره القدم حول العالم
لكن تشاء الظروف احيانا الى عدم تحقيق ذلك
الحلم نهائيا فهنالك اساطير لم تسمح لهم
الفرصه لتسجيل حضورهم في المونديال بينما
كانوا في اوج عطائهم الفني وفي افضل
المراحل في مشوارهم الكروي ذلك بسبب اقصاء
طبعا منتخباتهم من التاهل لنهائيات كاس
العالم ابرزهم مشاهدينا الوزير ريان احد
ابرز اللاعبين في تاريخ نادي مانشستر
يونايتد وتعثر عليه اللاعب في المونديال
اذ لم ينجح منتخب ويلز في الوصول الى
النهائيات عندما كان ريان لاعبا في صفوف
المنتخب
او جائزه افضل لاعب في العام 19
سواء 90 كاول لاعب فريقي بعد تالقه مع
انديه ميلان الايطاليه وموناكو وباريس سان
جيرمان الفرنسيين وعجز عن المشاركه
بالمونديال بسبب ضعف مستوى منتخب بلاده
ابدا طبعا جورج همم ويا ايضا اصبح رئيسا
لليبيريا والمفارقه يلعب ابنه اليوم في
المنتخب الامريكي
وسنخصص له فقره اليوم خلال التاسعه ايضا
من اللاعبين الذين لم يحققوا حلم
المونديال
الفرنسي اليك
كانتونه من افضل اللاعبين الذين لعبوا في
الدوري الانجليزي الممتاز بقميص مانشستر
يونايتد محرز اكثر من 160 هدفا في مسيرته
الكرويه وكان قريبا من المونديال
بمناسبتين في عام 1994 التي غاب عنها
المنتخب الفرنسي بعد خسارته
ماريا وفي مونديال
1998 فضل اميرجاكيه مدرب المنتخب الفرنسي
النجم زين الدين زيدان على كرتونه وهناك
ايضا النجم الايرلندي جورج بس همم صاحب
الكره الذهبيه في عام
1968 واحد افضل من لعب في مركز الجناح حول
العالم ولم يحقق هدفه بالظهور بالمونديال
بسبب عدم تاهل منتخب بلاده عندما كان
باوجه عطائه وفي القائمه ايضا النجم
الفريدو دي ستفعلوا ورغمه تمثيله لمنتخبين
دوريين وهما الارجنتين واسبانيا الا انه
لم ينجح في الظهور في المونديال سواء مع
التانجو او او اخيرا مشاهدينا النجم
العربي المصري محمود الخطيب الملقب ببيبو
ورغم انجازاته الكبيره والكثيره الا انه
لم يحقق حلم اللاعب نهائيات كاس العالم مع
منتخب الفراعنه لعدم تاهل المنتخب عندما
كان الخطيب باوجه عطائه وبالرغم من تتويجه
مع نادي الاهلي باكثر من 15 بطوله محليه
وخمس بطولات افريقيه وبطوله الامم
الافريقيه عام 1986 مع المنتخب الوطني
وحصولها على الكره الذهبيه من فرانس
فوتبول الخاصه بافضل لاعب بافريقيا الا ان
الحظ لم يسانده في اللعب بالموت يعني
[موسيقى]